ام
اهلا بكم في ما وراء الخبر الذي نقدمه لكم
الليله من العاصمه الروسيه تونس
اسدل الستار الليله عن اول انتخابات
رئاسيه مباشره تشهدها تونس بعد الثوره
ورغم ما اعلن عن اقبال متوسط على صناديق
الاقتراع في انتخابات برز فيها عزوف
الشباب بشكل رئيسي فان توقعات الشارع
التونسي من الرئيس المنتخب تظل كبيره وقد
اعلنت الهيئه العليا المستقله التي تشرف
على تنظيم الانتخابات الرئاسيه الجاريه في
تونس ان نسبه المشاركين في الانتخابات
داخل تونس بلغت نحو اربعه وخمسين في
المائه اما في الخارج فجاء متوسط نسبه
المشاركه نحو سبعه وعشرين بالمائه
كما هو طبيعي هناك التجاوزات تجاوزت
مختلفه ال اه عملنا ان اقاموا ميت عقبه
فيها هناك رسل هذه التجاوزات واذكر دائما
بان الهيئه تعمل على رقابه الحمله وخاصه
يوم الصمت الانتخابي لانه في الصمت
الانتخابي يكون تاثير هذه المخالفات اكثر
اثر على اراده الناخبين اذا لحد اليوم
الاول في العمل رصدنا عده مخالفات في هذا
على سبيل المثال في سيدي بوزيد تم اتهم
الى وجود سياره اداريه تنقل في اتباع حزب
معين اه الى مكاتب الاقتراع وقعت فيها رست
هذه تحرير محضر وتوقف المساحه العرب
باعتبارها جريمه انتخابيه
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه اذن مع ضيوفنا هنا في
الاستوديو توفيق استاذ القانون الدولي في
الجامعه التونسيه كذلك السيده للبحريه
رئيسه مركز الشاهد لمراقبه الانتخابات كما
ينضم الينا هنا من العاصمه التونسيه تونس
نور الدين العالمي استاذ علم الاجتماع في
الجامعه التونسيه اهلا بك كلام ابدا
بالسيد الليله انتم مركز الشاهد لمراقبه
الانتخابات قبل قليل قدمت الهيئه المستقله
اه انطباعاتهم ما رغبته في هذا اليوم
تكلمت بشكل عام على ان الانتخابات جرت في
ظروف طبيعيه مع بعض اه ال المخالفات التي
في العموم جرت في ظروف طبيعيه
يمكن اه اه هيئه المتابعه انتخابات كيفه
ملاحظاتكم
استهدافه للتصحيح انا اليوم مثلا تنسيقيه
شاهد
المتكونه من مراقبه الانتخابات والاتحاد
كان بودي ان نكون متفائلين مثلما كان اه
خطاب اه الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في ندوه صحفيه
بصراحه ما اللي حنا
اليوم عبر مختلف المنسقين الجهويين
للتنسيقيه في كل مراكز
الاقتراع هي اكثر من تجاوزات واكثر من
الخروقات لانه في اي انتخابات حتى في اعرق
الديمقراطيات
اه هناك تجاوزات والخروقات فما بالك ونحن
مؤسس الديمقراطيه اه نحن
نحن نتواجد ان تكون اه هذه الخروقات
والتجاوزات هي في اطار خطه مسطره وممنهجه
للسير بالانتخابات نحو نتيجه معينه وال
نحو اه
اولا هذا اول تجاوز وهذه وبالنسبه كبيره
تقريبا في كل الدوله الانتخابيه تواصل
الدعايه الانتخابيه
اه خلينا نقول محصوره في ثلاثه اربعه خمسه
مترشحين ليه فقط في محيط مراكز الاقتراع
ولكن كذلك بين الصفوف الناخبين والاخطر من
ذلك داخل مكاتب الاقتراع
ومن طرف بعض اعضاء ورؤساء مكاتب الاقتراع
معنا موثق بالاسماء يعني هناك بعض وما
اعضاء مكاتب الاقتراع يواجهون صراحه
الناخبين
فائده بعض المترشحين ثم كان ي
اه ان هناك خطه
ابعاد ممثلي بعض
المترشحين الانتخابات الرئاسيه من الحضور
اه في مكاتب الاقتراع هناك مكتب اقتراع
يعني اه المترشحين ليس لهم وجود لانه يتم
استبعادهم تحت حجه
وهي
ايضا
ملاحظه وم لاحظناه جميعا هذا اليوم فيما
يتعلق بهذه العمليه الاقبال المتوسط او
يقل قليلا حتى الان من قبل او ب طبعا
انتهت او اكثر صناديق الاقتراع وكذلك نسبه
الشباب ومشاركتها في هذه الانتخابات ما
السبب برايك اولا ان اه بحسب ما عشت في
اليوم اه اه الانتخابات في الاطار الذي
كنت فيه
ناخبا اه تمت في ظروف ممتازه اقول اه هناك
فيما يخص مساله اه نسبه المشاركه اه كنا
نامل ان تكون اكبر من هذه النسبه فعلا اه
مع الاسف هي جاءت باقل مما كنا نتوقع
وربما عزوف الشباب هو ال الظاهره التي
كانت
ملحوظه اه اليوم هذا يحتاج الى اه ربما
دراسه هذه الحاله ولكن عموما اه النسبه اه
معقوله اه نسبه مقبوله
ويمكن ان تكون اه نسبه تنبثق عنها نتائج
مقبوله ايضا اه فيما يتعلق بال تجاوزات
بطبيعه الحال اه
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات ادلت ب
ملاحظاتها اه في في هذه المرحله قد تكون
هناك ملاحظات اخرى لكن في الجمله اه لا
اعتقد ان هناك تجاوزات او مخالفه من شانها
ان تؤثر على طبيعه ونوعيه ال اه النتائج
طيب سيد نور الدين ما جرى هذا اليوم من
ملاحظات هل تونس مضت خطوه اخرى في طريقه
جربتها الانتقاليه بهذه الانتخابات
وانتهائها على هذه الشاكله هل يجب ان نركز
على مساله نسبه الحضور فى تثمين وقراءه
ودراسه ما قد تم جره عن هذه التجربه
اه اردت ان اكون اه قبل القدوم الى
الاستوديو متفائلا واه واردت ان ابشر
الشباب في تونس وشباب في الوطن العربي
باننا
انتخابات نزيهه
وصافيه وليس فيها مال فاسد لنقول ان
الربيع العربي برغم الانتكاسات الكثيره في
بلدان الشرق الى انه يفلح في تونس ويقدم
ونموذجا للانتقال الديمقراطي
ولكن للاسف الشديد ال اه الخروقات
الحقيقيه والمال الفاسد ظهر في الانتخابات
وتم
تثبيته بكثير من الادله واذا كانت ال
اللجنه الانتخابيه تريد ان تكون متفائله
لا يجب عليها ان تخفى علينا عمق هذه
الخروقات التي تمت فعلا من جوهر العمليه
الانتخابيه والديمقراطيه بصفه عامه اه لم
نستطع ان نفرح الليله بالنتائج الاوليه
التي بدات تظهر لاننا نحن نحس ان هناك
نتائج مشوبه بتدليس وانا شان نتائج مشوبه
ب اه ب بعض الغموض وقد لاحظنا كثير من ال
اه ال ال اه يعني
الاستاذ كيف لك ان تبني انطباع والنتائج
لم تقدم الى الان وعبيد يعني يعني لا زالت
في اه
مصادرنا ليست فقط ال اللجنه نحن نحن
قريبون من المراقبين و قريبون من كثير من
الاصدقاء الذين كانوا في المكاتب واه قد
عانوا الكثير من محاولات التاثير على
الناخبين واجتنبوا العنف لكي لا يردوا على
محاولات تاثير الناخبين من داخل المكاتب
انفسها يعني اللجنه الانتخابيه ليست
المصدر الوحيد لهذه المعلومات هناك كثير
من ال ال المراقبين من الاصدقاء الذين
يشتكون من محاولات التاثير على الناخب
ورفع شعارات سياسيه داخل مكاتب الانتخاب
نفسها فضلا على انه تم التلاعب بالكثير من
بطاقات ال المراقبين
وتحدثت اللجنه واللجان الفرعيه بكثير من
الحجج الواهيه اه اه للتخفيف حجم
المراقبين مرشح معين خاصه في العاصمه هذا
يجعلنا اه اقل زهوا بانتخابات ن او اقل
اعتزازا بها ونحن الذين اردنا ان نقدم لك
تجربه ناجحه للاسف الشديد ال ال الشارع ال
ال متحمس ل خاصه للدكتور المنصف المرزوقي
الشارع الان يعاني خيبه ال ال ال لانه كان
اه كانت حمله الدكتور موسى حمله فقيره
حمله بل اموال وبلادي وبلا دعايه علميه
وسيطرت عليها العفويه ونتائج هذه العفويه
ونتائجها
الى ان ادى الى ان نعم اه اشرت الى ما
وصفته خروقات تمت حتى الان وذكرتها المال
سيدنا بحريه لاسالها عن تحدث قبل قليل عن
وجود اه دعايه في مراكز الاقتراع او حولها
للتاثير على الناخبين وذكرت جمله اسباب
قلت بانها ربما قد تكون خروقات ومن مستوى
ربما يحذر من مصير التجربه الديمقراطيه في
في تونس هل هناك اه اه شواهد موثقه لما
ذكرته
اه
ودليل على ذلك انه
لانه وفق كل شيء اه عندنا احد ملاحظين في
الدين الانتخابيه بالقيروان اراد ان يصور
خارج مراكز خارج مركز الاقتراع اه ب
التجاوزات التي تقع ف تم القبض عليهم من
ترفع وان الامن
حجز معده وهنا نحمل الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات
ووزاره الداخليه من مغبه هذا التصرف يعني
اه كانت هناك ان هناك خوف من انه
التجاوزات والخروقات يقع توثيقها احنا
خلاف الحاله هذه كل كل موفق عنها احنا بل
انه عن ملاحظ وهو محامي في في الورديه في
يعني في تونس تم تهديده من طرف حزب معين
انه ينسحب والا يقع هذه ال كل موثق عنه
بمصداقيه
طبعا اذا كان يقع استبعاد
تحت حجج واهيه استبعاد ملاحظه بعض
المترشحين نقول اذا كان يتم استبعاد
ملاحظين مثلا
تشاهد من بعض مراكز الاقتراع اذا كان هناك
رؤساء مكاتب واعضاء مكاتب يريدون ان
يكونوا بمفردهم في مكاتب الاقتراع ان نقوم
مش تجاوزات او خروقات بل هي خطه ممنهجه
للسيد بهذه الانتخابات نحو وجهه وجه معينه
ونحن لم نتفاجا بهذه بل بالعكس من خلال
الحمله الانتخابيه في تابعناها المده
الفارطه كنا متاكدين انه هنالك خطه ممنهجه
للذهاب بهذه الانتخابات نحو وجهه معينه
اليوم الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
تتحمل مسؤوليه تاريخيه ليس فقط بخصوص
نتائج هذه الانتخابات ولكن كانت داعيه
المستقبل ناخذ تونسي ربما سيفقد ثقته في
العمليات
الموجود في الحديث عن الفاسد الحديث عن
التاثير على اه ربما حتى توجيه علامه
استفهام بالنسبه لما ذكرته الهيئه
المستقله للانتخابات وبالتالي الى اي مدى
ترى هذه الاطروحات لها ما يبرر خلال العام
حتى الوصول الى هذا اليوم في هذه المنطقه
على كل هو الموقف الاساسي يعتقد والتقويم
الاساسي دون انكار اهميه تقويمات اخرى
يرجع الى الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات
ويجب ان نلتفت الى ما تدلي به ان تكون
هناك بعض
الخروقات او تجاوزات هذا موجود في كافه
تقريبا الانتخابات ولكن كما قلت هناك ربما
في الانتخابات خروقات جوهريه كذا يمكن ان
تؤثر اذا كان من شانها ان تؤثر على مجرى
النتيجه فهناك اجراءات والقانون هو الذي
يطبق ولكن الاحداث العاديه التي تقع في
مكاتب الاقتراع هي تبقى مرفوضه لكن ال
الهيئه هي تقوم مدى اهميتها لكن انا اقول
لحد الان حسب ما اه راينا اه لا يمكن
التشكيك في اهميه وحتى مصداقيه هذه
الانتخابات انا لا ارى ما يدعو الى
التشكيك في ذلك اه بالعكس يعني اه اه نحن
اه مررنا في تجربه هامه تجربه الانتخابات
التشريعيه وكانت ناجحه ويصعب ان نجد مثل
هذه التجربه في بلدان عربيه اخرى وان كان
في بعض البلدان العربيه شهدت انتخابات اه
جيده لكن الان تعطي يعني انتخابات اه
حقيقه يعني جديره بالاحترام
والانتخابات اليوم الاقتراع في بالنسبه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه انا لا اراها ما الذي
اه يجعلوا مجال للتشكيك فيها والهيئه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات وهي صاحبه ال
المسؤوليه في ما يصرح به بصوره اساسيه
وغير قانونيه مع هذا مع هذا اسمحوا لي ان
ابرز ايضا ان اه هناك وضعا اه ربما غير
سليم من الاساس اه في القانون الانتخابي
طيب فيما يتعلق بالحرب
ثم نعود نفصل في هذه المساله وايضا فيما
يتعلق
العوامل التي اثرت في اه ان تصل الجريمه
التونسيه فيما يتعلق بالانتخابات اليوم
الى هذه ال النتائج طبعا
عن نسبه الاقبال وكذلك خاصه فيما يتعلق
بنسبه الشباب وما قتلوا اليه التجربه
التونسيه في مقبل الايام عندما تظهر ان
نتائج بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى في هذه الحلقه من وراء
الخام تاتيكم من العاصمه التونسيه اه تونس
نور الدين العلوي برايك الى اي مدى قد
تؤثر هذه النسبه المقدمه حتى الان نسبه
المشاركه اه نسبه المشاركين فيما يتعلق
بالاعمار في هذه الانتخابات في تحديد
بوصله المسار السياسي ومن سيجلس على كرسي
الرئاسه في تونس
للاسف الشديد ال الملاحظه الظاهره الى حد
الان هي اه عزوف
فئات الاعمار دون الخامسه والعشرين
ودون الثلاثين في بعض المرات عن المشاركه
الكثيفه في ال في الانتخاب اه احترنا في
هذا العزوف في الانتخابات التشريعيه ولم
نصل فيه الى اه تفسير علمي دقيق اه ما
زلنا نرى عليه شواهد في هذه المرحله وقد
نرى عليه شواهد اخرى في الدور الثاني من
الانتخابات لان هناك دور ثاني الان وقد
تاكد اه هل ان هذا الشباب يئسوا حبت وسبقت
عزائمه بفعل سيطره جيل الكهول على العمليه
السياسيه هل لان الخطاب السياسي لم
يتوجهوا بشكل مباشر هل لان مطالبه من
الثوره لم تتحقق في ظل سنوات قليله ال ال
الواضح ان هناك عزوف وانه يحتاج الى تحليل
وان الدراسات التي وان الدراسات العلميه
تتاخر في متابعه هذا التعليل اعتقد ان اه
هذا هو الشاغل الذي يجب ان يوضع الان على
طاوله الحوار ات السياسيه وعلى طاوله
المفكرين والجميع يقوموا فيه كلمتهم لماذا
الشباب اه اه الخطاب المفارقه الذي اه شغل
به السياسيون وخاصه طرح قضايا من نوع
صراعات مذهبيه وايديولوجيه اه اه اه خرج
بالنقاش السياسي الضروري عن اه عن ما
ينتظره الشباب اعتقد انه كانت هناك
انتظارات لتغيير من وان التنميه والحديث
عن ال ال القضاء على الفوارق الجهويه ووضع
قضايا الدستور فيما يتعلق
بالتمييز الايجابي نحو الجهات الفقيره كل
هذا تاخر وتاخر بسبب انشغال السياسيين
بقضايا من الخاصه و بزعامات هم المفرطه ان
صح التعبير واه ادى هذا الى انهم الشباب
اليوم كان في المقابل يراقبوا العمليه
الانتخابيه من بعيد ويسكت فيه يعني على
المشاركه وهذه تقريبا ظاهره عامه اعتقد ان
هناك قطيعه تترسخ بين جيل الخيول الذي
يسيطر على المشهد السياسي وبين اه جيل
الشباب الذي ينتظره اخرى من ال من ال من
الثوره علما ان الاستاذ علما ان الهرسله
الاعلاميه الشريره التي تسلطت على الشباب
وثبت عزائمه وصورت له الثوره كجريمه وقعت
يحققون هناك اعلام يصور الثوره كجريمه
ويزور الشهداء كمجرمين ويريد محاكمتهم كل
هذا ادى الى ان الذين قاموا بالثوره هو في
الغالب جيل من الشباب تحت ثلاثين سنه الان
ينظرون المشهد بسخريه مره ويعتقدون انه قد
تمت خيانتهم وهناك احتمال اما
اما احباط عفوا عما احباط كامل عن
المشاركه في السنوات القادمه وترك هؤلاء
الشيوخ يموتون اه اه في في كراسيهم او اه
اه عوده الى الشارع
عفوا
دراسه اه لماذا وصلت النسبه بهذا ال الشكل
في تونس طبعا دون ال ال التوقعات التي
سبقت هذه ان اسال السيده ليله بحريه عن
تونس تعرف اه حركه مجتمع مدني قويه ما
الذي فعلته هذه الحركه حتى تشجع الناس على
المشاركه في هذه الانتخابات المصيريه
والمهمه بالنسبه
اه صحيح انه المجتمع
زمن الديكتاتوريه
كان اه يعني ا يخدم مصالح النظام ولكن
كانت بعض الجمعيات
تعد على اصابع اليد الواحده اللي كانت
نافله
بعد الان بعد الثوره من ثمانيه في جمعيه
وال هنا سته عشره الف شرعيه في المجتمع
المدني ولكن ليست كلها جمعيات فعل لن اللي
هي مستقله فيها الكثير اللي يعمل لصالح
اجندات سياسيه معينه
وفي فتره المجتمع المدني في تونس اه في
حاجه الى اعاده التشكل اه يجب ان اه يعني
اه اه يفهم
تنسى انه يوم مساحه الحريات كبيره من يريد
العمل السياسي هناك حريه العمل داخل
الاحزاب من يريد اه يختار المجتمع المدني
يجب ان يكون على الحياد من جميع معناتها
الاحزاب ان اقول اه مسؤوليه المجتمع
المدني مسؤوليه الاعلام مسؤوليه السياسيين
مسؤوليه انه اه كانت تاريخيه وانعكست
وانعكست على نسبه المشاركه لانه منذ
الثوره الى الان الخطاب الذي يواجه
للتونسي هو م اذا ربحت من الثوره وماذا
ربحت من انتخابات ثلاثه وعشرين اكتوبر
2011 اه ال يعني اه لم يقع اه الالتقاء
بوعي الشعب تونسي انه الثوره هي مسار انه
خراب خمسين او ستين سنه من دكتور
الديكتاتوريه والفساد اه يمكن اصلاحه في
عامين او ثلاثه او خمس سنوات
وبالتالي اليوم الشباب اللي لم تقع توقيته
بالدرجه الكافيه يقول فعلا ماذا قدمت لانه
الثوره وبالتالي هو غير مهتم مطلقا بال
بالانتخابات وهذا سينعكس سلبيا عليه
المرحله القادمه وعلى الاستقرار وبالتالي
انا ب فيما يخص المجتمع المدني
يهتم بشان انتخابي انا لا اوافق الاستاذ
اشبه عندما يقول الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
احنا نعم ويقف
تنسيقي التشاد كانت دائما في دعم هذه
الهيئه لا نشكك في نزاهتها استقلاليتها
ونحوها مثل ما يفعله غيرنا
ولكن اه نلتقي بها
الهيئه تعمل تحت ظروف يعني بتاع الضغط ضغط
من المجتمع المدني من اجل الالاف من
السياسيين ربما هذا يخليها تكون السار
ولكن حان الوقت تكون صارمه في تطبيق
القانون المساله القانونيه
تربط مع ما قالته السيده بحريه الان في
خصوص تطبيق القانون عندي ملاحظه صحيح انا
اولا بالنسبه للتقويم ات ال متعلقه
بالانتخابات المجتمع المدني له دوره ايضا
وهذا مطلوب بالنسبه للشباب ربما تجربه
المجلس الوطني التاسيسي والمشهد السياسي
الذي افرزته والتفاعلات السياسيه التي
افرزتها ربما هذا جاء على يرصد يعني
لدراسه مستقبل مستقبلا ربما هذا من الامور
التي جعلت الشباب حاليا او نسبه كبيره من
الشباب اه لما اخذ اليوم عمليه الاقتراع
وكان منتظر منها ان تكون ان يكون الشباب
يعني حاضرا لان هذا مستقبله لدي ملاحظه
ايضا ان هذه الانتخابات فيها اه امر اه
ربما غير سليم من الاساس بخصوص مترشح معين
اقصد هنا مترشح السيد الوصف المرزوقي هو
اه رئيس الجمهوريه مؤقت ويتقدم للانتخابات
ايضا بهذه الصفه انا ك ملاحظه عامه ان هذا
غير مقبول كان عليه ان يستقيل قبل ان يدخل
هذه الانتخابات يعني من حقها ان يشارك
الانتخابات يترشح لكن عليه ان يستقيل من
منصبه اولا لماذا لانها لما نرجع الى
القانون الانتخابي الفلسطينيين وخمسين من
القانون الانتخابي ينص على ويجب احترام
تكافؤ الفرص
تكافؤ الفرص اه تصبح بشان تساؤلات بخصوص
مترشح من بين الجميع المترشحين وهو في
منصب رئيس الجمهوريه وان هناك اشكال
قانوني في ترشح سيد
العليا المستقله للانتخابات اه لم تقل اي
شيء في هذا الخصوص لم تقل اي شيء احنا انا
فقط هذه الملاحظه الناحيه القانونيه تكافؤ
الفرص يتطلب ان كل المترشحين يكونون
في نفس الاطار
لم يبق الا بعض
في حاجه اخرى ايضا في اقل من 10 ثواني
ايضا لا ننسى ان المترشح المنصف المرزوقي
يعني في اثناء الحمله الانتخابيه اه خلف
الفصل تسعه وخمسين بصوره خطيره لما نعطي
خصومه السياسيين
ايضا
العمليه
الاسماء لاننا على في يوم انتخابيه سيد
نور الدين اه اه ما الذي تحقق هذا اليوم
لو تكرمت
ال الذي تحقق ان اه امثال الاستاذ ابو
عشبه من خبراء النص متوازيه النص الذين
احترفوا تاويل اهم ما زال يحدثنا عن
الخروقات ال الجزئيه وعن توهم اه اكتمال
المس القانوني دون ان يلمح الى ان المجلس
التاسيسي قد قدم لنا اه اه دستورا اه في
غايه في ال اه في ال في الكمال ان صح
التعبير
اجتماعات اه كثيره نعتقد ان اه امثال
المشرعين الذي والحقوقيين والذين يروجون
لكمال النص شكليات النص يتجاهلون ال ال
العمق الواقعي الحقيقي الاعتراف لم يكن
على شكل الترشح الرئيس الذي قبلته اللجنه
التي يقبل السيد بوش بان تكون لجنه اه
صادقه وحقيقيه فيما يتعلق بالخروقات
ولكنها ليست ليست كذلك فيما يتعلق
بالحكومه
الضيوف يمنعون السيد
الاحتلال العالم الاجتماع في الجامعه
التونسيه كما اشكر ضيفي الاستاذ توفيق
بعشره استاذ القانون العام والدولي في
الجامعه التونسيه واشهر اخيرا ضيفه السيد
ليله اه بحريه من التنسيقيه الشاهد شاهد
تعريف اذن هي الشاهد لمراقبه الانتخابات
شكرا جزيلا لك
الى اللقاء باذن الله
ام